68 tage lockdown und millionen deutsche
sagen jetzt reicht's vor allem würde
händler friseure wollen vom
wirtschaftsminister wissen wann können
wir endlich wieder aufmachen endlich
wieder geld verdienen
sie alle können das den
wirtschaftsminister gleich selbst fragen
hier live bei bild die richtigen fragen
an wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
ja und hier ist sein live im studio
schon guten abend heitmeier 100
teilweise verstehen sie sich als
wirtschaftsminister gewissermaßen als
anwalt der wirtschaft also ich mache
nichts anderes weil ich
wirtschaftsminister bin und seit der
pandemie erst recht wir haben über 80
milliarden euro mobilisiert für die
wirtschaft wir haben für die
kurzarbeiter für familien geld
mobilisiert aber die frage ist doch was
muss ein verantwortlicher
wirtschaftsminister der möchte dass die
wirtschaft auf die beine kommt tun wenn
wir zu früh den lockt dann aufheben dann
haben wir möglicherweise eine dritte
welle und den nächsten lockten vor der
tür und wenn was zu spät machen dann
halten viele unternehmen nicht mehr
durch weil ihnen die luft ausgeht das
ist das große dilemma und wir müssen
einen vernünftigen weg führen und dem
wissen wir auch erklären damit jeder
weiß warum wir so oder so entscheiden
es gibt ja auch so eine rollenverteilung
innerhalb der regierung und die
kanzlerin hat diese woche gesagt in
diesem bürger tag den sie abgehalten hat
hat sich so ein bisschen flapsig gesagt
ich bin ja immer so die stränge
da könnte man ja vom wirtschaftsminister
erwarten dass der der nicht so streng
ist und der ist er dann der erste ist
der für die wirtschaft kämpft dass die
wieder locker dass sie wieder öffnet das
der jeden tag eigentlich daran schraubte
an konzepten wie es wieder losgehen kann
also ich halte nichts von
rollenverteilungen ich glaube dass eine
bundesregierung beschlossen handeln muss
und dass sie eine gemeinsame botschaft
aussenden muss und jetzt vor dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
kommenden mittwoch in drei tagen ist die
botschaft eigentlich von markus oder bis
zu stephan weil
von angela merkel bis zu haben laschet
und auch einschließlich peter altmaier
und olaf scholz dass wir
selbstverständlich an öffnungs
strategien arbeiten dass die zahlen aber
noch zu hoch sind um konkret
die schritte jetzt schon zu verantworten
das muss man sagen obwohl uns das
wahnsinnig schwer fällt also für
lockerungen wollen sie im moment mit
wirkung sofort nichts wissen die gute
nachricht ist dass die infektionen die
letzten zwei wochen deutlich wissen sind
sie sinken jede woche um etwa 20 prozent
im vergleich zur vorwoche
das kann man ganz kurz angucken 41 jahre
alten mann kommen uns die zahlen noch
mal angucken wie sich das im lockdown
verändert hat also wie der lok down
gewirkt hat sozusagen das ging ja los im
november mitwirkung anfang november
zweiter november dann sind die zahlen
erst mal weiter auf geklettert und dann
wurde es ziemlich rot im ende dezember
und wir waren am anfang vom lockdown
eben knapp 200 und sind mittlerweile
deutlich unter 100 inzidenz wert und
nähern uns immer weiter so dieser 50 an
und jetzt könnte man sagen menschen in
die 50 erreicht sind dann dann schafft
man es aber wieder also die 50 wollen
wir erreichen und das wäre ein toller
erfolg
aber wir haben derzeit im wochenschnitt
pro tag etwas weniger als 10.000
infektionen und als wir im frühjahr den
ersten lok dann verhängt hatten hatten
wir gerade mal 5000 das heißt die zahl
der infektionen ist doppelt so hoch im
vergleich zum letzten früher wo wir
gehandelt haben und deshalb ist mein rat
als bundeswirtschaftsminister dass wir
alles aber wirklich alles tun damit die
zahlen schneller runter gehen damit sie
absehbar untergehen und damit die leute
auch das licht sehen am ende des tunnels
für die gastwirte für die ist wichtig
dass sie anfangen können wieder zu
verkaufen und zu machen und zu tun wenn
die sonne scheint wenn man draußen
tische aufstellen kann
wenn die leute auch das bedürfnis haben
wegzugehen pizza zu essen gut bürgerlich
zu essen ich glaube darauf müssen wir
hinarbeiten und es ist ja nicht mehr
drauf machen ist wenn die sonne scheint
dass es noch weitere manchmal sehen ja
heute was für wetter in deutschland ist
toll dass ich einfach noch ein weiter
weg bis zum frühjahr das heißt jetzt
können sie schon sagen geschäfte handel
die können sich erst mal darauf
einstellen dass die geschlossen bleibe
ich entscheide das ja nicht ich habe
heute als minister
eine stimme oder einen ratschlag den ich
nehmen kann
wir werden gemeinsam entscheiden
ich gehe davon aus dass momentan
jedenfalls der der weg zu lockerungen
noch einige tage oder wochen dauern wird
weil wir diese positive tendenz nicht
unterbrechen dürfen also wenn sie
schmerzt ihn vorher war einige wochen
zähle ich jetzt sage ich ich ich leg
mich ich denke ich da nicht fest weil
ich hab mich auch ärgern würde wenn die
ministerpräsidenten oder meine
kabinettskollegen mehr öffentliche
ratschläge erteilen würden wie ich zu
entscheiden habe am mittwoch sondern wir
haben drei intensive tage vor uns wo wir
ringen und dann ist ja auch die frage
ist ja auch die frage dass es ganz viele
gruppen gibt die sagen wir können nicht
mehr lange durchhalten das sind die
eltern die ihre kinder zu hause betreuen
die sagen wann geht die schule wieder
los das sind die wirte die jetzt schon
fast vier monate geschlossen das sind
die friseure die friseure wieder auf ja
ja der hat wahrscheinlich nicht so
geschickt wie ich mir die haare selbst
zuschneiden
aber bei mir ist ja auch kein kunststück
weil es nicht mehr so viele sind aber
ist hinterlegt ja nicht nur um uns die
wir uns jahre schneiden lassen sondern
auch um die diese ich sehe nicht dass
die wollen geld verdienen das sind ganz
viele sind ganz viele die betroffen sind
und deshalb müssen wir auch das ist dann
eine lehre aus der korona pandemie wir
müssen darauf achten dass es gerecht
zugeht
wir können nicht von heute auf morgen
von null auf hundert alle sozialen
kontakte wieder zu lassen weil das dazu
führt aus erfahrungen aller länder um
uns herum dass die ansteckung und sofort
wieder durch die decke gehen und damit
wäre niemandem geholfen dass uns noch
mal ganz konkret bei den friseuren
bleiben
täuscht der eindruck dass sie da so
langsam eine ganze branche gegen sich
haben ja ich glaube dass es nicht nur
die friseure sind ich glaube dass jeder
unternehmer der seit die friseure sind
geschlossen seit 15
dezember die gaststätten sind
geschlossen seit erster november das
sind vier monate demnächst und das sind
menschen die sind verzweifelt zum einen
weil sie ihre ersparnisse ja auch
aufbrauchen niemand können wir alles
erstatten was er verliert
und es sind ganz ganz viele die durch
diesen lockdown einbußen haben hinnehmen
müssen wir helfen wo wir können ja aber
die der entscheidende punkt ist der
entscheidende punkt ist doch dass wir
gesehen haben
erst als wir zusätzlich zu den
gaststätten zu den hotels zu den
kampagnen dienstleistungen dann auch
noch schweren herzens die friseure und
den einzelhandel denn nicht lebensmittel
handelt ist ein runter schlossen erst
dann sind die zahlen runter gegangen und
zwar nicht weil die friseure oder die
einzelhändler keine guten
schutzmaßnahmen hatten die waren sehr
gut
aber in dem moment wo die menschen in
die innenstädte kommen in dem moment wo
sie in den bussen und in den wahn und
setzen sie sich verstecken sie sich an
und das ist genau der punkt wir uns
umtreibt das ist einmal mit ein paar
dieser bisschen verzweifelten
friseurinnen im moment sprechen nämlich
mit renate klink spur aus münchen mit
celtic aus hattingen und mit sabine
klotz die frisörin in mannheim ist ihnen
allen dreien schönen guten abend
wir sind jetzt gerade schon bei dieser
thematik altmaier hat gesagt er
schneidet sieht jahre selbst zumindest
vorübergehend einige kollegen können das
nicht aber sie wollen ja vor allen
dingen wieder arbeiten frau klingspor
können sie uns einmal sagen ob sie oder
wie sie im moment schon vom start von
den altmaier von herrn scholz
entschädigt werden gar nicht entschädigt
das weiße altmann auch ganz genau
eigentlich wollte ich fragen ob wir uns
15 wieder öffnen aber diese bedenklich
hat sich jetzt erledigt nach den
aussagen
obwohl frau merkel immer gesagt hat die
ersten öffnen das ins reserve bis in
schulen und das sind kitas
ich wollte ihnen auch mal fragen wie
schaut das denn aus gibt es
testergebnisse aus dem hervorgeht dass
nach dem log da sich irgendwelche
menschen bei interessieren angesteckt
haben oder infiziert haben bei dem
pumpwerk haltmayer der akan verein ja
die also ich muss ihnen sagen ein großes
kompliment für die friseure die friseure
haben tolle sicherheitsvorschriften
gemacht hygienemaßnahmen abstände masken
alles hervorragend das hauptproblem
besteht darin dass wir verhindern müssen
dass zu viele menschen in öffentlichen
nahverkehrsmitteln unterwegs in den
fußgängerzonen unterwegs sind sich nahe
kommen die sich nicht kennen
und damit des virus verbreiten das ist
der grund wir haben zu anfang nur die
privaten kontakte eingeschränkt dann
haben wir die gaststätten und die
restaurants geschlossen und am ende
mussten wir schweren herzens auch die
friseure und auch die modeboutiquen und
die bekleidungsgeschäfte schließen und
dann gingen die zahlen runter aber nicht
weil sie fehler gemacht hätten sondern
weil weniger menschen auf den straßen
unterwegs waren überzeugt sie das volk
linken spur
es ist natürlich bitter wenn man selber
alles gemacht hat und dann sagt man ja
ja die leute stecken sich halt in den
städten in den bahnen und bussen an und
deswegen muss sie ausschließen dass
dentist oder gibt es keine test wie
irgendwelche ergebnisse vor
dass die menschen sich bei den friseuren
angesteckt haben ich habe noch keinen
einzigen erlebten die gesagt hat er ist
als bisher infiziert wurden ein gut
immer muss allerdings der wahrheit die
ehre geben und sagen dass ungefähr 80
prozent der menschen nicht wissen wo sie
sich angesteckt haben
weil nämlich dieser test ja es positiv
ist mehrere tage 19 tage nach der
ansteckung und dann weiß der betreffende
eben nicht ob es beim einkauf im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel war in der s
bahn beim friseur oder anderswo und weil
wir so viele infektionen hatten konnten
die gesundheitsämter das auch nicht
rückverfolgen wenn es wenige gibt dann
kann man sagen okay du warst beim
friseur war es im lebensmittelgeschäft
du warst im restaurant und jetzt schauen
wir mal ob da irgendwo in der zeit
infektionen aus natürlich für frau
klinger spur ist auch vielfältig und
frau klotz eine ganz wichtige frage muss
man ehrlicherweise sagen kein mensch
kann sagen wir vermuten deswegen haben
wir komplett die ganze branche recht
gemacht aber beweisen können was leider
nicht leidet war nicht anspricht wir
haben nicht die branche fest gemacht
weil mein mann das sieht man man sich
bei den versteigerungen anstreichen
sollten uns den weg dahin genauso
erstanden
nächste frage aber noch die müssen wir
auch ganz kurz klären von frau klinger
spur war nochmal fünfzehnter februar
noch mal ganz konkret das heißt von
kling spur sagt nee das war im grunde
schon neun von ihnen wird nein nein ich
kann es doch ich habe es eben gesagt ich
selbst entscheide es doch gar nicht
es kommen zusammen 16
ministerpräsidenten die bundeskanzlerin
und das halbe bundeskabinett
und dann wird besprochen und dann wird
überlegt und es gibt wünsche bei den
kitas etwa
was zu tun es gibt die frage bei den
friseuren da gibt es einen großen druck
es gibt auch welche die sagen es ist
jetzt vielleicht noch zu früh und wie
das am ende dann ausgeht dass wissen wir
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal am
mittwochmorgen sondern am mittwoch wenn
die ministerpräsidenten und die
kanzlerin zusammensetzen frau sell
schick können sie uns können sie hatten
altmaier einmal ihre corona rechnung
aufmachen
ja ich hatte mir mal guten abend
erstmals punkte ausgestiegen ich wäre
ganz glücklich wenn ich die loswerden
könnte bei ihnen los geht's ja es geht
los die finanziellen hilfen sind noch
nicht da wir haben 0 1 waren seit
dezember aber bleibende kosten wie
einkommensteuer vorauszahlungen
umsatzsteuer miete etc
wir haben wirklich 0 1 kommen dann
kommen die hilfen wann wird ausgezahlt
wann wird uns geholfen
wir sind arbeitgeber wir haben
mitarbeiter die wir ja auch noch
irgendwo doch halten müssen
wir halten auch ich meine wir sind auch
freizügig sage ich mal gehen und
konzepte noch verschärfter zu machen wir
sind so nah an menschen und am kunden
dran die ärzte juristen polizisten
pflegepersonal das sind ja schon
berufszweige die geimpft worden sind
vielleicht sollten wir als nächstes auch
mit in die gruppe kommen dass wir uns
impfen lassen freilich ganz sicher wann
kommen die hilfen lassen sie uns erst
mal da soll er also in ihrem fall bin
ich überzeugt dass sie noch im monat
februar die abschlagszahlung bekommen
können
sie müssen den antrag stellen können das
ist geplant im laufe des februar dann
kommen innerhalb von ein oder zwei tagen
die abschlagszahlungen das ist dann bis
zu 50 prozent ihrer fixen kosten maximal
100000 euro im monat das erreicht nicht
jeder weil die unterschiedlichen die
einen zahlen mieter die anderen zahlen
eine ich will aber vielleicht weil er
alles konkret ist sagen wir haben fünf
milliarden ausgezahlt seit ende november
für diejenigen die wir im november schon
geschlossen hatten und wir werden für
die war am 15 dezember geschlossen haben
jetzt ende februar mit den
abschlagszahlungen beginnen es gibt aber
jetzt schon die möglichkeit natürlich
ist er gut ist das schnell aus ihrer
sicht ja weil es geht ja darum es geht
ja darum dass wir pro betrieb bis zu 1,5
millionen euro erstatten
an kosten die diese betriebe haben und
die kommen schnell zusammen
und das kann man natürlich nicht auf gut
glauben und und vermutung machen sondern
das muss weil das geld der steuerzahler
ist ja in irgendeiner weise vom
steuerberater bei angefangen schweren
und großen geprüft werden und dann
entschieden werden aber ich will sagen
es gibt es gäbe ja für sie auch die
möglichkeit schon die ganze zeit die
überbrückungshilfe 2 in anspruch zu
nehmen und da werden fixkosten wie die
miete und strom und wasser und heizung
die werden erstattet für die mitarbeiter
gibt es kurzarbeitergeld und das läuft
eigentlich schon seit dem ersten oktober
und wenn sie dann antrag gestellt haben
dann müsste das geld eigentlich da sein
oder in den nächsten tagen kommen und
das andere das viel günstigere was dann
noch obendrauf kommen weil wir ihnen ja
diesen lockt dann noch zumuten mussten
das wird ende februar mit den abschlag
das heißt es ist eigentlich alles da sie
müssen noch ein bisschen geduld haben
frau klotz sagte er
der wirtschaftsminister und dann kommt
das schon wie sieht das bei ihnen aus
also normalerweise geschäftsleute müssen
ja immer pünktlich zahlen da wollen die
angestellten pünktlich das geld haben in
dem moment vielleicht kurzarbeitergeld
aber da muss eben die miete pünktlich
gezahlt werden und alle fixkosten die
man sonst hat und auf das geld vom staat
wartet man leider lange wie war es bei
ihnen frau klotz ihnen herzlichen
glückwunsch dass dieses jahres selbst
schneiden können leider ist es bei der
kundschaft nicht so beziehungsweise kurz
oder lang wie gut auch ein brot das
geschäftsschädigend wasser altmaier
macht eigentlich nicht wir nehmen's
trotz der ganzen bande mit humor
aber es muss auch mal gesagt das ist
einfach unser existent ist
wir verdienen damit unser geld
haare schneiden daher sei die gesundheit
oder gar kein thema aber wir in mannheim
wird es höhere anzahl den 19 12 2020
schon geschlossen
das heißt unser weihnachtsgeschäft ging
komplett flüge und bis jetzt aber wir
keine gelder zu beantragen
wir fangen nicht ständig über prüfungs
hilfe 2 und die überbrückungshilfe 3 ist
erste beantragen mitte februar das heißt
bomba werden kann eltern alleine sagen
50 prozent der hörer existenzminimums
und angelangt die gesundheit geht vor
gar kein thema aber es müssten die
versprochene gelder einfach lesen am
schönsten wird seine existenz sterben
gebenhofen und wir müssen selber und
gute mittelstand lebt in staat und also
ich verstehe nicht warum das diesmal so
kompliziert ist es waren im frühjahr
machte unkompliziert jahr rege okay wir
vereinfachen können
aber da ist es geld geflossen und dann
kann man überleben und dann kann man
sagen
ist es realistisch weil man es noch auf
jetzt in prag schloss aber aber
teilweise aber unsere kollegen schon
termine gemacht
nach dem 15 wie oft sollte man das
machen muss so recht erschließen okay
dann darf am öffnen oder ist wird noch
viel eher wenn ihr euch nicht niveau
verspricht da ist ja gar keine zeit mehr
zum plan große organisation und das kann
man sich gar nicht vorstellen rechnet
einfach
also ich versteh ich verstehe sie
wirklich weil ich auch in meinem
bekanntenkreis meiner familie menschen
hab denen es ganz ähnlich geht wie ihnen
und deshalb vielleicht der frage zu der
frage warum kann man das nicht im voraus
entscheiden weil wir eben im voraus
nicht wissen wie die dinge sich
entwickeln und dann müsste man einen
viel längeren lockdown entscheiden um
auf nummer sicher zu gehen
das möchten wir aber nicht an weil die
verzweiflung ja noch größer
sie können aber auch nicht sagen aber am
ende ist es ja genau darauf
hinausgelaufen muss man jetzt zumindest
in der rückschau sagen erst haben sie
gesagt nur für vier wochen immer wieder
nur für vier wochen diese
pressekonferenz gab es ja wohl wieder
das gesagt hat frau merkel das gesagt
hat der müller auch nur vier wochen und
mittlerweile sind wir bei 68 teilen wir
haben gesagt wir machen ist für die
nächsten vier wochen weil im gesetz
steht länger als rauchen dürfen die
länder das nicht um die geschäftsinhaber
zu schützen ich klar ist man genau die
erwartungen genau zuhören und dann sagen
das war ja und dann war da muss ich habe
das heute auch bei ihnen in der bild am
sonntag gesagt im interview und das
teile ich mit winfried kretschmann
wir hatten zu anfang eben viel zu weiche
und lockere maßnahmen und trotzdem die
gaststätten geschlossen ab erster
november mit dem ergebnis dass die
infektionszahlen weiter nach oben
gegangen sind und dadurch haben wir zwei
monate verloren und das war ein großer
fehler
deshalb haben wir uns alle geschworen
dass wir hoffnungen machen so schnell
wie möglich aber sie müssen vertretbar
sei nur in der rückschau umso mehr herr
altmaier müssten sie zumindest meiner
auffassung nach der anwalt von denen 3 1
sein und deren interessen vertreten und
die fühlen sich allein gelassen die
haben wir seiner teilweise keinen cent
gesehen obwohl ihnen zumindest teilweise
die hilfen zu stehen und wissen ja
überhaupt nicht wie das weitergeht aber
ich habe ich versucht er zu erklären
ich hab' ich hatte im frühjahr die
soforthilfen ja vorgeschlagen und die
haben wir innerhalb von 14 tagen
ausgezahlt jedenfalls in nordrhein
westfalen und in berlin und in vielen
bundesländern
das waren insgesamt 13 milliarden für
drei millionen unternehmen und jetzt
geht da ging es aber um beträge bis zu
zehn oder fünfzehn 1000 d-mark nicht
mehr
und da werden übrigens jetzt überall
rückforderungen gestellt weil gelder
auch zu unrecht und zu hoch ausgezahlt
wurden
und jetzt geht es um beträge bis zu
anderthalb millionen und das ist etwas
was sie nicht einfach so überweisen
können wenn der antrag kommt weil ich
glaube dass alle die hier sitzen mit
denen wir diskutieren das sind ehrliche
unternehmerinnen die ihn mit sicherheit
niemals falsche angaben machen
das sind halt eben nicht alle nur wenn
man wenn man es über das terrain sehr
als man nur wenn man damals
es ist die die nachteile oder die
umsatzverluste dieser drei sind so hoch
dass sie sich so schwer tun das zu
prüfen dass es bei denen länger dauert
ja aber das heißt natürlich aber dafür
haben wir eine haben wir einen keine
lösung aber eine hilfe
niemand muss zum insolvenz und konkurs
anmelden weil er die miete oder dass die
oder sonst etwas nicht bezahlen kann
wir haben extra das gesetz geändert und
haben gesagt bis ende april muss niemand
der eine solche hilfe beantragen kann
klar die insolvenz aber wovon leben sie
denn im moment frau zach wovon leben sie
denn im moment wie wie bestreiten sie
ihren alltag haben sie ihr erspartes
etwas erspart hatte ich natürlich meine
alters man alltag ersparnis was ich halt
hatte das ist aber schon längst
aufgebraucht also muss ich einen kredit
aufnehmen und das ist nicht einfach zu
zeiten kredit aufzunehmen
ich hätte da noch ein vorschlag wir
bräuchten zumindest steuererlasse für
diese zeiträume haben sie damals schon
mal darüber nachgedacht
ja es gibt steuerstundungen das ist
sache des kollegen scholz dann trotzdem
zahl was nutzen mir das wenn ich
stundungen mache ich fange an zu
arbeiten
ich arbeite ich kann ich kriege ja gar
nicht in ausfall so schnell wieder
eingeholt
also muss ich dann da für den kredit
arbeiten nein es ist es ist so wir haben
es und stundungen ist ja das was sie
angesprochen haben und ihre kolleginnen
dass die steuervorauszahlungen machen
müssen alle drei monate
und das kann man stunden und dadurch das
ist weniger drückend zweiter punkt wir
haben einen verlust drückt rat
beschlossen schon im juni
das heißt sie können verluste aus diesem
jahr an rechten auf die steuern die sie
im jahr 2019 gezahlt haben das war bis
zu vier millionen
das haben wir jetzt ausgedehnt auf bis
zu zehn millionen und das bedeutet also
wenn sie gewinne gemacht haben im
letzten oder im vorletzten jahr
dann können sie diese steuern die sie
gezahlt haben zu einem teil oder auch
ganz wieder zurückbekommen
ich habe manchmal auch das gefühl dass
wir nicht nur in der politik manchmal
langsam sind und zeit brauchen und ich
haben manche
auch das gefühl dass die beratung vor
ort vielleicht nicht so ist wie sie
eigentlich sein sollte ich hatte einen
einen bekannten der hat gesagt er ist
durch alle durch alle prüfer gefallen
weil irgend so eine klausel verhindert
hat dass er hilfe bekommt oder ruft man
stellte sich da stehe ich aber mein
eindruck ist dass in seinem fall gab es
eine sonderbestimmung und er konnte die
mein eindruck ist dass 30 super
informiert haben und dass die drei genau
wissen was sie ihnen was sie ihnen
zusteht ist zumindest mein eindruck hier
aus der ferne
was würden sie sagen wenn sie die
geschichte von frau klinger spur von
frostig von frau klotz hören gehen sie
davon aus dass ein oder zwei von den
dreien vielleicht in einem jahr ihr
geschäft nicht mehr haben zwangsläufig
ist es nicht weil wir ja die hilfen
beschlossen haben und die hilfen kommen
werden und viele hilfen werden ja auch
jetzt schon gezahlt zum beispiel auch
kredite wir haben diesen 800.000 euro
sofortkredit auch für die kleinen
unternehmen möglich gemacht schon vor
einem halben jahr
aber was mir große sorgen macht ist dass
viele unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
mutlos werden weil sie so lange
schließen möchten wenn jemand sich
selbständig macht dann macht er das weil
er gerne den menschen die haare schön
macht und wenn er ein gaststätten
restaurant eröffnet weil er gerne für
sie kocht oder gerne geselligkeit hat
und all diese menschen sind verzweifelt
weil sie wollen ja unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer sein und das tut mir so weh
wir haben in deutschland viel zu wenig
menschen die sich selbständig machen in
den letzten jahren immer gehabt und
meine große sorge ist dass wir den einen
oder anderen verlieren den wir dringend
brauchen weil sie so einen großartigen
beitrag leisten zu unserer kultur und zu
unserer identität jetzt haben wir eine
längere diskussion schon erlebt im land
über fußballspieler zum beispiel die
immer wieder mal die haare geschnitten
hatten auch über fernsehmoderatoren die
immer mal wieder ihre haare geschnitten
hatten und auch über die bundeskanzlerin
die vergangene woche im interview gesagt
hat mensch ich habe meine assistentin so
war ihre
ihre formulierung in diesem interview
wir viele wissen ich habe da ja
bekanntermaßen unterstützung durch eine
assistentin die macht die frisur ist
vermutlich auch geprüft hat es noch
keiner aber vermutlich alles legal und
trotzdem frau klingsporn man kann so ein
bisschen verstehen wenn man da auf der
zinne ist man selber steht mit der
schere oder dem rasierer in der hand
möchte wieder ran und ganz ganz viele
millionen deutsche warten auf die
termine wieder bei ihnen und die
kanzlerin kriegt die frisur gemacht
da hilft sozusagen
ich frage mich wo ich der unterschied
zwischen einer hilfe und der kanzlerin
und wo ist der unterschied zwischen
mitarbeitern die bei uns arbeiten
wie hält man das was seehofer hat es auf
den punkt gebracht er hat gesagt öffne
die schere den die schwarzarbeit wächst
was sagen sie dazu
ich glaube dass das ein sehr ernstes
argument ist
ich habe mit dem kollegen seehofer mich
darüber auch schon vor 14 tagen drei
wochen ausgetauscht weil wir beide
eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich im
richtigen leben verwurzelt sind und
wissen was im richtigen leben vor sich
geht und ich glaube in der tat wenn es
schwarzarbeit gibt dann ist das
gesundheitlich natürlich viel
gravierender als wenn sie in einen
friseursalon kommen wo alle
hygienevorschriften eingehalten sind und
alles bestens vorbereitet das heißt wenn
die drei ehrlichen die gerade vor ihnen
sind altmaier wenn die alle jetzt
schwarz arbeiten würden und das würde
die ganze branche machen im moment
machen es nur einige wenn es die ganze
branche machen würden dann wird das
beste argument wieder zu öffnen
also erstmal ist es so dass wir hier
nicht von ein paar schwarzen schafen auf
die ganze branche schließen dürfen
ich weiß dass die allermeisten ehrlich
sind zweitens wenn diese schwarzen
schafe auffallen dann müssen sie auch
mit ordnungs und bußgeldern rechnen aber
je mehrere schafe es gibt das ist dass
die allianz und von den sie ja mehr
druck zu öffnen ich weiß wie wir wir wir
haben alle diese wir haben alle diese
dringenden wünsche vor uns und jetzt
diskutieren wir hier mit den friseuren
ich kann das verstehen aber es gibt auch
ganz viele tausend gastwirt
genauso von der eifel kommen willkommen
wir auch sagen und sagen mein restaurant
nicht klar das stinkt nachricht nach
abgestandenem bier und abgestandenem
essen weil wir eben dort seit vier
monaten drei vor allem klingen spur hat
ja nicht nur gesagt herr altmaier
sie müssen unbedingt die friseure wieder
aufmachen natürlich ist dass das
geschäft der drei und natürlich wünschen
sie sich dass aber die haben vor allen
dingen eines gesagt wir brauchen eine
perspektive
wir wollen unseren kunden irgendwie
sagen solange noch das war das
hauptargument hat sich das aber ganz
sicher auch davon aus dass die
perspektive bald kommt wir arbeiten ja
an öffnungs konzepten die bundesländer
tun dass das kanzleramt ist ich tue es
als bundeswirtschaftsminister und wir
überlegen fangen wir an bei diesem oder
jenem mit je fangen wir an dort wo die
zahlen ganz niedrig da wird man das nach
der nach dem mittwochstermin wissen also
weiß frau klingspor wenn folgende
voraussetzungen bei mir in münchen
erfüllt sind dann darf ich meinen salon
wieder öffnen weiß sie dass nach dieser
woche also nach irgendwo wenn ich das
wüsste
weil der mittwoch sind noch drei tage
aber ist das sehr zielgenau das ist so
erreichen wir müssen wir müssen uns
darüber verständigen in welcher wenn es
gut geht
nach welchen prinzipien und kriterien
wie eröffnungen vorbereiten
aber ich würde davor warnen zu sagen wir
öffnen jetzt schon zu sagen wir öffnen
die gaststätten vor den hotels oder die
hotels wurde in gaststätten weil ich
genau weiß dass diejenigen die dann
später geöffnet werden total verzweifelt
sein werden und sagen was haben wir denn
angestellt dass es uns so trifft und
deshalb wäre es ja eigentlich ganz gut
man könnte auch lockerungen in gang
setzen
die mehrere branchen betreffen und da
muss man sich auch sehr genau die
regionale situation anschauen wenn sie
einen landkreis haben wo ganz wenig
infektionen sind und in allen
landkreisen drumherum auch nicht dann
ist es eine andere situation als wenn
sie einen haben wo es gerade noch
einigermaßen okay so nebendran ist ein
super hot spot mit über 300 ansteckungen
pro 100000 einwohner also verstehen sie
sich von selbst verstehen sie dann mit
den ländern absprechen und ich wünsche
mir dass die länder die kraft haben dies
so zu entscheiden dass es in jedem
bundesland einheit
nicht angewendet wird weil das
schlimmste ist wenn dann die menschen
mich anrufen und sagen herr altmaier ich
komme aus rheinland pfalz in oder aus
baden württemberg und bei uns müssen wir
noch dicht machen und die anderen dürfen
schon jetzt morgen bei ihnen kunden
anrufen oder kunden anrufen frau celtic
und sie fragen was hat er denn jetzt
gesagt könnten sie es sagen also könnten
sie es ihren kunden sagen der altmeiler
meint das so wird das laufen also ich
werde wahrscheinlich halbstündig
telefonate führen es mit einer halben
stunde dauern bis ich das verstanden
habe so wie ich es verstehe den kunden
das rüberzubringen
es wird lange schwierig sein den kunden
das verständlich zu machen
so jetzt einmal eine ganz andere sache
die legalität
da will ich noch mal ganz kurz in die
verfolgungsjagd hat auch angefangen es
sind kunden die uns wirklich oder mich
zumindest wirklich verfolgen und sagen
können sie mir die haare bitte zu hause
schneider können sie bitte dieses mein
beruf ist zur zeit illegal und das muss
ich wirklich sagen verletzt mal ein buch
wäre also es ist wirklich die zeit mal
ausdrücklich zu sagen wir müssen jetzt
mal wirklich sagen was machen wir ärzte
pflegepersonal die arbeiten alle auch so
nah wir sind dienstleister also herr
altmaier sie haben sozusagen sie nicht
sie persönlich aber sie haben den
friseurberuf zu einem illegalen beruf
gemacht sagt frau feld schicken nein
heißt nein das kann man so nicht sagen
weil die menschen sich an die gesetze
halten müssen
davon gehen wir auch aus und es gibt ja
auch ganz viele andere körpernah
dienstleistungen die geschlossen sind
und zwar schon seit langem
fitnessstudios beispielsweise und und
andere massagepraxen und alle sagen wann
dürfen wir wieder öffnen und ich wäre
ein schlechter wirtschaftsminister wenn
ich sagen würde die friseure auf jeden
fall und die anderen müssen mal schauen
irgendwann weil ich die sorgen und die
not der friseure verstehe aber glauben
sie mir die fitness studios waren
geschlossen bis weit in den sommer und
in den herbst in einigen bundesländern
und sind wieder geschlossen seit dem
ersten november die
haben demnächst ein jahr in dem sie kein
geld verdient haben die veranstaltungs
betriebe die messe aus wir sind ein
ganzes jahr so es gibt durch diese
pandemie so entsetzlich viele dramen die
entstanden sind und deshalb versuchen
wir das abzug lindern und zu finden zu
helfen wo wir können
wir haben 20 milliarden 23 milliarden
man kurzarbeiter geld ausgegeben
das geht nicht an die unternehmer das
geht an die beschäftigten natürlich aber
es hilft auch die beschäftigten zu
halten dass man wieder loslegen kann
wenn die öffnung möglich ist okay einmal
strich drunter ich will noch einmal das
ganz kurz mit der kanzlerin aufnehmen er
ist das finden sie das eigentlich völlig
in ordnung finden sie das völlig in
ordnung weil die kanzlerin ist weil sie
es darf weil sie in der öffentlichkeit
steht oder ist es schon komisch und
vielleicht auch moralischen bisschen
nicht mehr ganz sauber wenn sie die
geschichte der drei hören na ja wissen
sie als ich heute abend zu ihnen rein
gebeten worden bin und dann hat man mich
in einen kleinen raum gebracht wo eine
maskenbild ganz genau
die mit großer professionalität dafür
gesorgt hat dass ich von weitem
einigermaßen entfernt aussehe
und ich habe auch schon beim talk shows
erlebt wenn ich dann irgendwo ein paar
strähnen hatte die abstanden dass die
maskenbildnerin diene friseure
ausbildung hatte dank gesagt hat das
schneiden war gleich ab und ganz ähnlich
ist es mit der kanzlerin auch dass das
auch erwartet wird dass sie in der
öffentlichkeit ihr land repräsentiert
und vertritt
ich glaube das hat sie auch ganz ehrlich
und offen gesagt und auch bild oder oder
der springer konzern hat gesagt ja bei
uns ist das auch so wir haben auch
maskenbildner und die sind im einsatz
das kann man nun diskutieren man kann
sagen warum geht der wirtschaftsminister
nicht mal mit langen haaren zu den
richtigen fragen oder herr weise und
anderen aber ich denke dass das dass das
problem ändert sich dadurch nicht dass
eben millionen von menschen sehnsüchtig
darauf entsteht dadurch dass im friseur
gehen müssen das jetzt gar nicht an der
kanzlerin fest machen aber wir waren
auch über fernsehmoderatoren sprechen
über youtube usw wenn man den fernseher
anmacht beispielsweise hat man manchmal
das gefühl da ist gar kein locker und
oder wenn man sieht am flughafen dass
eine klientel nach dubai fliegt und dort
nach wie vor urlaub macht da gilt dann
plötzlich kein lockdown aber es gilt
halt für millionen deutsche hier lockt
dann hat sich so eine zwei klassen
gesellschaft etabliert die einen die
sich an die regeln halten müssen und für
die anderen gilt irgendwie dann doch
einen weg dass die regel doch nicht so
ganz genau also ich finde dass es auch
dass es auch geschmacklosigkeiten gibt
und dass jeder der der etwas tun kann
was vielleicht egal es sich immer auch
fragen muss ob man das in anderen
zumuten kann ob das ein gutes beispiel
ist
ich bin zum beispiel mein eigenes haus
ist im saarland
ich wohne dort alleine da muss ich ab
und an mal hin alle paar wochen ich habe
das als der lok dann besonders scharf
war so gemacht dass ich eben nicht im
flieger geflogen bin sondern selbst mit
meinem auto gefahren bin wo ich
niemanden getroffen habe und niemanden
gefährdet habe und ich weiß dass ganz
viele menschen das ähnlich tun und ich
glaube es ist jetzt auch nicht der
richtige zeitpunkt um nach dubai oder
anderswohin zu fahren sondern es ist der
zeitpunkt zu zeigen dass wir verstanden
stehen verstehe jetzt wollen wir einmal
ganz kurzen abschluss machen mit frau
celtic mit frau klotz und mit frau
klingspor der wirtschaftsminister hat
sich hier erklärt hat auch erklärt warum
die eine oder andere hilfe die sie so
dringend brauchen noch nicht geflossen
ist was können sie halt mal den dreien
heute abend mit auf den weg gehen wenn
sie sich nicht mehr solche sorgen machen
müssen wenn sie vielleicht ein bisschen
ruhigere nächte haben also die
überbrückungshilfe drei habe ich gesagt
die soll bis ende februar
anträge und abschlagszahlungen
und dann natürlich ab märz die richtigen
auszahlungen kurzarbeitergeld ist
gesichert bis ende des jahres und wir
wollen öffnen sobald es vertretbar ist
aber das kann man nicht vier wochen im
voraus wissen und wenn die zahlen weiter
so sinken wie jetzt
und wenn die mutationen sich nicht
ausbreiten wie die pest dann glaube ich
das licht am ende des tunnels jetzt so
langsam sichtbar wird leider noch vage
der wirtschaftsminister hat erklärt aus
seiner sicht warum das so ist es ist im
moment bleibt noch unbefriedigend frau
klingspor celtic frau klotz danke ihnen
dass sie das gespräch hier gesucht haben
heute abend mit dem wirtschaftsminister
österreich geht der momenten anderen weg
die öffnen ab morgen wieder einiges
zumindest friseure zum beispiel sind
geöffnet geschäfte in bestimmten rahmen
auch finden sie das richtig finden sie
das gut
es ist ja doch recht nahe geben unseren
österreichischen freunden keine zensuren
aber ich will sagen dass wir eigentlich
alle den fehler doch gemacht haben die
österreicher waren im sommer viel besser
als die deutschen die hat eine ganz
tolle erfolge mit der bekämpfung der
pandemie und dann sind sie trotzdem eine
ganz ganz schwere zweite welle hinein
gerasselt sowie die allermeisten länder
um uns herum und so finden sich nicht
richtig im moment dass sie den eindruck
muss man das muss man in österreich
beurteilen ja das ist ja dichter in
deutschland also sie spüren sie werden
die folgen direkt spüren in deutschland
ja der hre haben wir haben wir haben
natürlich in den grenzgebieten immer
auch dass wir folgen spüren an der
grenze zu tschechien an der grenze zu
österreich
es war ja auch so dass möglicherweise
die ersten infektionen etwas mit
wintertourismus zu tun hatten im letzten
jahr hat man gehört
trotzdem finde ich dass wir mit respekt
über unsere nachbarn reden sollen das
hat ja nicht wie aspekt und wählen ja
oder nein ist wir nehmen uns doch das
recht dass wir beurteilen wann wir
öffnen können und wenn wir glauben es
ist vertretbar dann tun wir es auch um
frage ist doch ob das ob das uns
deutschland also der braucht man gar
nicht zensuren verteilen an die
österreicher da kann man kann man sagen
das ist für uns einfach nachteil wenn
die österreicher große öffnen wenn die
tschechen groß erlernen und deshalb
haben wir gesagt und deshalb haben wir
gesagt wenn die infektionszahlen wieder
hoch gehen dann müssen die alle damit
rechnen dass wir auch maßnahmen
ergreifen um zu verhindern dass die ihn
aktion nach deutschland hinein ist
einzig der csu-generalsekretär sagt so
was sie in die richtung heute der sagt
die friseure sind nicht die gefahr
sondern die grenzen sind im moment die
gefahr für deutschland die größte gefahr
geht nicht von friseur aus sondern von
der grenze sagt er wortwörtlich in einem
tweet heute markus blume das heißt
grenzen dich dann wenn wir sehen dass
die infektionszahlen erweitere auf glas
ist das ist so einfach weil wir nämlich
beispielsweise jetzt schon für
hochrisiko gebiete wo die mutationen
vorkommen beförderungsverbot erlassen
haben die fluggesellschaften dürften
bürger von dort nicht nach deutschland
bringen sofern man natürlich von
österreich nach dollar genau und das
zweite und das zweite ist ich finde es
auch schade jammerschade eigentlich dass
wir nicht imstande sind in der eu
gemeinsame regeln festzulegen wann
geschlossen werden muss wann geöffnet
werden kann weil das risiko ist überall
gleich wir leben in einem binnenmarkt
mit offenen grenzen und dann sollte sich
jeder eigentlich nach vergleichbaren
kriterien verhalten ok heißt ja nicht
dass alle den deutschen hinterher laufen
man hätte sich heißt dass wir gemeinsam
ja das hat übrigens angela merkel
versucht ich glaube auch unterstützung
bei ihren kollegen im europäischen rat
aber leider gottes nicht genug können
sie sich können sie verstehen wir gerade
ganz viele mit den friseuren gesprochen
können sie verstehen dass sich viele
unternehmer in deutschland jetzt im zuge
dieser krise von ihrem
wirtschaftsminister ja fast verraten
fühlen weil erst der wirtschaftsminister
ist der die komplette wirtschaft
runterfährt nein das ist ja falsch was
sie sagen sie es total falsch wir haben
eben die wirtschaft nicht komplett
heruntergefahren
der gesamte bereich der industrie des
produzierenden gewerbes
wer ist nicht runtergefahren und das ist
auch ganz wichtig dafür dass wir denen
denen wir einschränkungen zumuten müssen
auch helfen können damit die konjunktur
in gang kommt die deutsche konjunktur
ist seit september wieder gewachsen
die arbeitslosigkeit ist seit september
wieder gesunken saison bereinigt und das
ist das ist ein deutliches zeichen dafür
dass er mit der wirtschaft eigentlich
sehr gut umgegangen sind und in manchen
bereichen vielleicht noch ein bisschen
besser als anderswo in europa
mit den gesundheitlichen
herausforderungen dann lassen wir uns
einmal diskutieren nochmal sie haben
gerade schon wird er angesprochen sie
haben auch andere unternehmer
angesprochen wie beispielsweise
einzelhändler christian hartmann ist
einzelhändler aus weinstadt bei
stuttgart und uns zu gestaltet ebenso
zugeschaltet hans eder der hat eine
kartbahn in altötting in der alten
heimat des papstes und fragt dies die
knast zu gestalten der ein gastronom aus
bad friedrichshall ist das ist in der
nähe von heilbronn werden sie vielleicht
kennen wohl nicht ganz so ganz so weit
entfernt davon haltmayer und beginnen
wollen damit ihnen hartmann schönen
guten abend auch bei ihnen einmal die
frage nach ihrer ganz persönlichen
corona rechnung einzelhändler
modegeschäft in weinstadt verstärkt
hatten wir erst mal katastrophal
man kann es wirklich anders
zusammenfassen wir kämpfen wirklich um
jeden euro umsatz gehen ja auch im
geschlossenen zustand machen können und
ich habe mir die zahlen auch
veröffentlicht um transparenz zu
schaffen und auch einfach mal
darzustellen was wirklich an hilfen
zurück kommen ich weiß nicht ob sie es
einspielen können wir können einmal ganz
kurz zeigen sie haben uns ein ein einmal
ihre kassen zahlen sozusagen vorab zur
verfügung gestellt
vielleicht können sie einmal selbst
erläutern hat man also umsatzverlust in
corona zeiten das betrifft wie viel
monate bei ihnen das betrifft
tatsächlich den kompletten lockdown bis
31 erst mitte dezember und ist betrifft
den ersten job down von mitte märz bis
mitte april
diese umsatzzahlen die da veröffentlicht
sind die sind tatsächlich auch nur für
den lockdown der umsatzverlust und im
vergleich zum vorjahr gesetzt und sieht
mit 8,43 prozent wie die solidarität
unserem bundeswirtschaftsminister
wirklich aussieht darf ich eine frage
stellen
sie stellt sich hier steht derart liche
hilfen bekommen von 17.600 euro
da sind ja vermutlich noch nach kräften
dabei die sie bekommen werden vom 15
dezember bis solange der lok dann dauert
denn da wird er die antragsstellung erst
jetzt im februar möglich sein
das ist teilweise richtig es ist nämlich
so dass er für dezember nicht
anspruchsberechtigt sind wir keine 30
prozent umsatzminus erwirtschaftet haben
weil es eher nicht den schließungszeit
raum als grundlage nehmen sondern den
ganzen dezember das müssen sie auch noch
mal erklären wie das denn möglich ist
und dadurch gibt es für dezember nicht
es ist richtig dass die januar zahlen
fehlen die momentan nicht mal beantragt
was sie tragen sie mein steuerberater
was er ihnen zu ihren
überbrückungshilfen desaster eigentlich
sagen will also die wissen selber
inzwischen nicht mehr was sie da genau
machen sollen wie sie es machen soll die
faq es ist ein wirklich ein heilloses
durcheinander und bürokratie ohne ende
das kann man sich nicht vorstellen dass
sie sich im moment erwarten
wie finanzieren sie sich im moment hat
man ja ja der staat zwingt mich dazu
mich zu verschulden und zwar ganz
einfach meine bank sagten ja also hör
mal zu hört man ja du kriegst sitzen die
viertelmillion neuware die kannst du
nicht abstellen weil erste von neun bis
zwölf monaten schon bestellt die trudelt
jetzt ein
sie sehen das ist ungefähr der betrag
der mir ein umsatz verlorengegangen ist
aus dem betrag bezahlt ich das ganze
normalerweise kann ich jetzt nicht jetzt
habe ich die möglichkeit entweder ich
melde insolvenz an oder ich nehme
staatliche kredite auf die sich der
staat mit drei prozent verzinsen lässt
und das heißt aber zu hören von sechs
prozent aufnehmen
das heißt er hat man sagte altmaier die
bundesregierung hat mich zum schuldner
gemacht
ja das gab es ja ganz das gilt für ganz
viele unternehmen die 80 milliarden die
wir zur verfügung gestellt haben
davon sind ungefähr ungefähr die hälfte
darlehen die wir über die kreditanstalt
für wiederaufbau kfw gegeben haben an
die unternehmen und das hat etwas zu tun
auch mit den regeln der europäischen
union über staatliche beihilfen die für
alle mitgliedstaaten geld sind was sind
leute bei denen das geschäft lief die in
die schulden gemacht haben die gut
dastanden und die jetzt sagen ach der
start der war sie bis zum schuldner weiß
aber es gibt es gibt natürlich auch ganz
viele arbeitnehmer denen geht es genauso
das sind die die jetzt in der kurzarbeit
sind und weniger netto nach hause
bringen als die ganze zeit und wenn zwei
ministern und frau sowie zwei ehepartner
in kurzarbeit sind dann fehlt manchmal
viel fest haben wir hinein kommen wir
haben eine wirtschaftsschrumpfung im
letzten jahr von fünf prozent und das
hat eben nicht alle getroffen ist gibt
welche die haben gut verdient im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel in der
industrie in anderen bereichen haben die
umsätze sogar geboomt zum teil und
andere haben deshalb mehr als fünf
prozent die haben zehn 20 30 40
rückgänge und das ist das ist wirklich
dramatisch für die betroffenen aber wir
haben nur in einem einzigen fall gesagt
dass wir umsatzverluste erstatten
das waren all die geschäfte die wir
schon am ersten november geschlossen
haben und auch nur für die monate
november und dezember
die bekommen 75 prozent ihres
ausgefallenen umsatz her jeder wie lange
hat ihre kartbahn jetzt dicht wie lange
es da kein betrieb früher für 300
geschlossen
sein erster november wieder geschlossen
ich habe 35 mitarbeiter eben nur selber
noch beschäftigt weil wir uns geeinigt
haben auf einen sehr kurzen knackigen
durchgang uns versprochen wurde
da wird ja auch wieder entsprechend
beendet was natürlich nicht
stattgefunden
ganz deutlich im moment geht es um ein
umsatzausfall seit neben beginnen ihre
pandemie von 550.000 euro bisher
erhaltenen hilfen film dank altmaier
38.000 euro
natürlich hilft das ist nur ein tropfen
auf einen heißen stein und er
schleunigst ich mir heißt in wir zwar
zerreißen
ich sage ihnen das mal ganz deutlich
bedeuten weil die kartoffel ist ein gold
96 ich liebe dieses geschäft nicht wegen
der rendite nicht wegen dem hochsetzen
ich liebe es wegen den kontakt zu den
menschen die in dem sozialen umfeld und
weil ich motorsport vom markt war schon
für kinder nach verwachsen sind das dann
ganz neuen einfach sein können einfach
schön finde
und ich möchte meinen geschäft beenden
ich habe meine gesamte altersversorgung
die ich von meiner frau und von mir nun
bereits wieder ins geschichten steckt
die hat mich mir eigentlich seit 1996
hart gearbeitet wir haben nicht die
verbieten wenn sie 75 prozent wie im
november vom umsatz anbieten
dann wäre das ein sehr hilfreicher
ansatz gewesen aber wenn es irgendwann
so ist das ihr dann viele dinge in
abzukommen wie die kurzarbeiter geld
kosten und service an
und wer am ende die merken dass wir in
etwa auf eine quote von 23 prozent
kommen die wir dann vom umsatz haben
dann passiert wir nicht mal in einem
bereich wo wir uns da irgendwie was
schaffen könnten dass es dann immer die
zeit bringt in der tat weit von der
bundesregierung einfach kein geld kommt
hier sehe ich eine zahlung nicht ganz
ganz langsam 100 und alleine das dass
sie vorher noch sachen ja für januar
können sie ja noch gar keinen antrag
stellen die kürzlich aus dem brief
stehen daher entschuldigen sie sie
müssen sich dafür schämen antragstellung
das wäre ganz einfach hören die könnte
am ersten tag funktioniert ja ich also
erst einmal entschuldige ich mich dafür
das ist mir wirklich ernst dass es so
lange dauert
zweitens können sie mir glauben wenn ich
irgend eine möglichkeit gesehen hätte es
zu beschleunigen ich hätte es gemacht
und ich werde zum fuß gelaufen bis zu
ihrer kartbahn aber tatsache ist dass
die bundesländer die die hilfen des
bundes
ausführen und verwalten und die beamten
zur verfügung stellen in ihrem
förderbanken uns erklärt haben sie sehen
sich außerstande die überbrückungshilfen
und die und die umsatz erstattung
november/dezember hilfen was die anträge
angeht die aufnahme und die bearbeitung
zunächst zu administrieren
der finanzminister ging ja um
umsatzausfälle und die
länderfinanzminister haben gesagt wir
können das auch nicht über die
finanzämter machen und wir haben dann
eine lösung aus dem boden gestampft
quasi über nacht wo wir über eine
internetplattform die plattform
überbrückungshilfe de
diese dinge organisieren und das muss
programmiert werden weil nämlich jede
bedingung ja gelöst werden muss und
jetzt sage ich ihnen
wir haben bei den überbrückungshilfen ab
januar haben wir bis vor wenigen tagen
gestritten auch mit dem kollegen im und
und diskutiert mit dem kollegen im
finanzministerium weil immer wieder
menschen kommen und sagen ihr müsst das
mal machen ihr habt das vergessen das
ist so ungünstig das geht nicht und sie
können aber erst anfangen wenn das alles
feststeht wie sollen denn die beamten
wissen was sie auszahlen wenn die
einzelnen bedingungen noch nicht geklärt
sind und das ist etwas wo wir zu
schwerfällig sind wo wir schneller
werden müssen und wo wir hoffentlich
lernen wenn wir das nächste mal in einer
ähnlichen situation sind ich will die
sache mit den kurzarbeiter noch
aufklären
also wir haben gesagt sie kriegen 75
prozent vom umsatz den sie im letzten
jahr im november und im dezember hatten
und natürlich haben sie damals ihre
mitarbeiter bezahlt und das war teil
ihres umsatzes und jetzt sind die in
kurzarbeit und dann bekommen die ja ihre
bezahlung von der bundesagentur
und deshalb wird es abgezogen ansonsten
wäre es ja eine über kommt ganz schnell
räder wie finanzieren sie sich im moment
hatten sie irgendwelche rücklagen
die anzapfen konnten und jetzt musste
ich schon erwähnt habe die alte zeuge
wurde komplett aufgezehrt oder die uns
kredite bereits begonnen und sie noch
kurz vor aber ich wollte ja schon noch
mal kurz darauf einginge alba ich kann
das schon rechnen
ich verstehe auch den abzug oder mir ist
es wichtig dass einmal deutlich zu sagen
wissen sie ich stresse auf den straßen
menschen die mir sagen oberholz es ist
schön dass viele und 75 prozent vom
umsatz polizei jetzt richtig gut aus die
gastronomie hat er wirklich ein
schnäppchen gemacht und das ist doch so
ein blöder man von der fdp in der
talkshow und erzählt den leuten wie sich
die gastronomen letzten einfach machen
mit 1 75% warum nehmen sie dann so eine
zahl in den mund wie in der realität gar
nicht stattfindet und ganz ehrlich
nochmals ich spreche jetzt aus meiner
situation dann aus ich ärgere mich dass
pression in den norden aufgeben müssen
ich finde das schlimm
man könne den ich schnell helfen da gibt
es oft nur ein kleines schild das könnte
sogar comunale erledigt werden auch mal
ganz einstellen eben dazu komme ich so
ideen und einen wirtschaftsminister
stadt eine wirtschaftlich starke meiner
wirtschaftsminister würde kämpfen
kämpfen dafür dass die firmen arbeiten
können und ich wieder die neuregelung
sich einfallen lassen wie man die noch
aus brands haben und noch mehr migration
warum ist denn zu sein muss sie sind
eher für uns jetzt wo ist die bundesliga
ist die familie der hersteller land und
leuten die uns alles das ist der punkt
der bei vielen unternehmen bleibt haben
sie wirklich bis zuletzt haben sie bis
zuletzt alles menschenmögliche getan
dass endlich nach sein geld bekommen hat
dass er sein geld bekommt aber aber
haben aber natürlich es gibt kein land
in europa das ähnlich viel geld bereits
ausgezahlt hat wie deutschland es gibt
kein einziges nicht frankreich nicht
italien sind alle ja selbst schon
langsamer als sich dafür entschuldigt ja
natürlich aber ich kann doch ich kann
doch nicht ich kann doch nicht den
bundesrechnungshof die gesetze die
gerichte alles außer kraft setzen und
sagen hier kommt nach
wirtschaftsminister und der entfernt wir
machen
sie haben gerade gesagt die länder sind
am ende jetzt zu langsam in dem
verfahren das hat sich langsam an ich
weiß ich ich verteile keine nicht an die
länder sich noch andere ministerien
annehmen
ich sage ja ich sage ich verstehe doch
ich verstehe noch ihre enttäuschung ich
verstehe es nicht doch aber sehen sie
mal 20 stunden am tag arbeiten und sagen
man muss ich schlafen
das heißt ich kann ich kann am
wochenende arbeiten ich kann ich kann
bis nachts arbeiten aber trotzdem kann
niemand die welt verändern und das
prinzip dass man eben nicht sagen kann
wir geben jetzt einfach mal jedem 50.000
oder 100.000 euro das dürfen wir nicht
durch die eu wir müssen alles genehmigen
lassen
ich habe mit den kollegen zusammen das
versprechen das versprechen der ärgert
herren das versprechen der ärger denn
jeder so wahnsinnig das versprechen ein
als sie war noch geschadet habe bei der
die leute über das jahr macht sich ganz
kurzfristig war jenas aber die lieber
super das war in einem konkreten
situation hat der stolz gesagt jeder
kriegt einen kredit der den kredit haben
will und dann haben die banken gesagt
uns reichen die sicherheit nicht und
dann haben wir den 800.000 euro
sofortkredit gemacht wo der bund 100
prozent der haftung übernehmen
november hilfe und konnten die besucher
ja gar nicht verwandt ich weiß dann muss
ich ihnen sagen ich habe nie gesagt es
stoff sich jemand die taschen voll mit
der umsatz erstattung oder er hat ein
geschenk bekommen nein wir haben doch
die umsatz erstattung gemacht weil wir
sie für notwendig
das versprechen 75 prozent vom umsatz
haben einige leute gesagt hoher der
gastronomie hits aber richtig gut da
muss ich jetzt dafür auf der straße
verteidigung das wird der die naz
wahrscheinlich auch canon mit seinem
nord bahnhöfle gegners vermutlich genau
dieselben probleme oder sind sie
mittlerweile an die helfen gekommen
also ich selbst gerade hier und
schüttelt so ein bisschen den kopf weil
man jetzt genau in den gesprächen oder
es ist alles sehr viel versprochen
worden
es ist nahezu anfang der versprochen
worden unwahrscheinlich
die leute zu beruhigen weil natürlich
alle angst hatten was ist jetzt los mit
dem beschließen müssen man verdiene geld
und dann hieß es natürlich von
regierungsseite eher keine sorgen
kümmern uns um ihr bekommt ganz schnell
hilfen und solche kleinwort nie ganz
schnell
ja da ist man natürlich dann hellhörig
und ihr ziehen ja was das dilemma ist
die wolken sitzen da auch hier gastronom
und warten rückt die versprochenen die
abschlagen seinem restaurant von herrn
gegners schon damit habe ich daran diese
haben sagt die abschlagszahlungen sind
zum teil gekommen oder noch nicht
gekommen
zum teil gekommen ja ok ja und marcell
was und man hat die versprechen gegeben
um zu beruhigen um vielleicht auch sich
selber zu beruhigen und zu sagen mensch
da haben wir jetzt so ein riesen
aufstand im land dann werden die nämlich
schon alle im november sauer gewesen
wenn sie es nicht versprochen hätten
also und jetzt sehen sie dass die hilfen
nicht gekommen sind oder zum teil
gekommen sind und merken halte an dem
anderen machen das ist ja nur für mich
sagen ist ja es werden ja jeden tag
hunderte interviews gemacht
von allen möglichen beteiligten ich habe
immer gesagt wir werden bei den november
hilfen dafür sorgen dass noch im
november die anträge gestellt werden
das war am 25 der fall und wir werden
noch im november beginnen mit den
abschlagszahlungen das war am 27
der fall und wir haben inzwischen von
den beantragten november hilfen 3
milliarden ausgezahlt beantragt sind
insgesamt fünf milliarden
und zwar nicht nur abschlagszahlungen
sondern seit drei wochen sind die länder
jetzt wieder dran und es wird
abgewickelt und wird ausbezahlt und ich
gehe davon aus dass wir sehr schnell die
fortschritte machen aber ich verstehe
auch und deshalb ich bin doch nicht der
gegner von denen die hier zugeschaltet
und ich bin in der tat deren anwalt ich
verstehe doch wenn man auf glühenden
kohlen sitzt und darauf wartet dass das
geld kommt dass jeder tag ein tag zu
lange ist und deshalb habe ich ja auch
gesagt mir tut das von herzen leid aber
es war bisher von all den kritikern noch
nie noch keiner da ich rede ist nicht
von ihnen ich rede von denen die auch in
der politik dann denkt na da kann die
opposition
mal gesagt das ist ja eigentlich noch
weitere auch in ihm ist dass er gesagt
hat wie es schneller geht es war noch
niemand da der gesagt hat wie es
schneller und das ist ja eigentlich noch
bitterer
ja das ist ja noch das ist nicht
funktioniert erst rechtlich dass es
nicht funktioniert was ich mit ihnen
arbeite ich habe ja ganz verboten habe
ja angebot habe gesagt passt auf ich
gebe euch das gerne ab wenn ihr das
wollt und ihr glaubt ihr kriegt das geld
schneller an die frauen an den mann dann
könnt ihr das tun
über sparkassen und raiffeisenbanken und
volksbanken über die kommunen über die
finanzämter es hat sich niemand gemeldet
und niemand darum gerissen und wir haben
diesen job übernommen war nicht zutiefst
davon überzeugt bin dass eine frage der
gerechtigkeit ist dass wir das geld zu
den menschen bringen und als uns dann
klar geworden ist dass es in einzelnen
fällen halt eben dann auch dauert bis
ende februar vielleicht sogar bis in den
märz bis alles erledigt ist sind wir
hingegangen und haben gesagt dann darf
aber niemand in der zeit heißt von der
anwender schneller als das
wirtschaftsministerium stelle als das
finanzministerium das ja auch zuständig
ist hätte niemand hingekriegt es hat
jedenfalls niemand sich gemeldet und es
hat uns auch niemand versucht herr
gegner ist ganz kurze abschlussrunde mit
ihnen drei betätigen das gehen sie davon
aus dass sie im sommer das ist ja die
perspektive von herrn altmaier gewesen
wenn die sonne wieder scheint dann
könnte es wieder so weit sein dass die
restaurants dass die gastronomie bilder
eröffnet gehen sie davon aus dass die
geschäfte noch haben
also ich hab heute eine nachricht gehört
in der tagesschau dass herr altmaier
und ich möchte bis ostern dann
vielleicht ja nackenlinie vorstellen das
ist wieder so einen kleinen anlauf gibt
aber wenn ich zurückschaue habe ich
meine zweifel nicht die letzten monate
oder sagen wir wirken in der angenehm
waren es von nina von der
bundesregierung ein hilfloser
aktionismus ohne jeglicher strategie
egal in welche richtung es geht mir
graut ist jetzt schon davor dass kitas
und schulen auf machen was ich für
richtig finde aber wahrscheinlich wieder
ohne konzept weil sie dann wieder in den
schulbussen und in den u bahn sodass sie
müssen
meinen sie dass sie noch länger
geschlossen haben müssen das stark eine
strategie dahinter ist das ist also das
man gut vorgesorgt haben viele zumindest
tische auseinander gestellt zelte
belüftungsanlagen große investiert und
in den schulen saß meistens halt ein
bisschen anders aus als du manchmal doch
jena ganz kurz auch bei an sie die frage
gehen sie davon aus dass ihre kartbahn
am leben bleibt werden sie vielleicht
besser gefahren sie hätten die kartbahn
dichtgemacht zu machen alle leute
rauszuwerfen dass es lagerhallen zu
verbieten was brauchen wir auch viele
leute in der zukunft amazon würde sich
wohl freuen würde ich auch nicht tun
jederzeit
und da ist weiterlesen wenigsten
geöffnet aber eigentlich möchte ich
ihnen ganz deutlich sagen für mich ist
dass sie mit 53 jahren normalerweise
immer ein bisschen voraus langen kann
ich kann nicht ich habe mir vorstellen
dass wir im april/mai vielleicht was nun
dürfen dann machen wir auf aber mein
geschäft kommt zu zwei dritteln von
oktober bis jetzt april soll ich dann
mit dem oktober wieder zurückkehren
ich glaube ihre geschichte nicht zweiten
von von einem großteil der gesellschaft
bis zum sommer zu machen und wird nicht
funktionieren dass wir gleich darauf ein
bis drei jahren aber wenn ich zwei bis
drei jahre jedes hinter geschäfts wuchs
er muss dann sagen sie es mir leicht
weil dann mache ich irgendwas ohne pass
männer alle ich glaube an meine wünschen
allen dreien dass das funktioniert dass
es so schnell wie möglich eröffnet er
hat es mit in der hand das zu
beschließen wir alle hoffen irgendwie
auf eine perspektive auf einen
stufenplan ich glaube das würde schon
ein bisschen ruhe reinbringen weil es
eine perspektive bringen danke danke
gegners danke hartmann auch und ja
hoffentlich ist das eine oder andere
so eindringlich gewesen dass es doch
noch mal beschleunigt wird wir haben
darüber gestritten ob das alles
menschenmögliche gemacht wurde von ihm
von der politik genau dieselbe frage
stellt sich beim impfen im moment ist
ihr eindruck von der bundesregierung von
sich selbst auch das ist nicht ihr
erster zuständigkeitsbereich aber dass
sie könnten für die impfstoffproduktion
beispielsweise zuständig mit zuständig
sein in deutschland dass sie
diesbezüglich alles menschliche möglich
gemacht haben dass in deutschland im
stoff produziert wird also der kollege
jens spahn war ja letzte woche bei ihnen
und hat umfassend rede und antwort
gestanden
wir helfen alle mit in der
bundesregierung der finanzminister der
wirtschaftsminister um die
voraussetzungen zu schaffen
ich habe im sommer des letzten jahres
dafür gesorgt dass wir eines der
erfolgversprechendsten impfstoff
unternehmen mit einer staatlichen
beteiligung hier in deutschland gehalten
haben es klang gestern den
rechtsseitigen ja es geht wie es geht um
die produktion wo man diese unternehmen
diese unternehmen brauchen
produktionsstandorte die sind aber nicht
innerhalb von 14 tagen aus dem boden zu
stampfen weil das hochkomplizierte
anlagen sind deshalb müssen sie
zusammenarbeiten mit anderen und zum
beispiel das unternehmen pure weg dass
wir in bayern zusammen die corporate
zwei jahre die kooperation das ist
schneller land produzieren zu können
verzeihen wenn ich noch einmal kurz
unter euch genau das ist der punkt sie
sind das vergangene woche auch am
sonntag bei anne will gefragt worden
und sie hat gefragt eben auch ob sie das
menschenmögliche getan haben und da war
ihre antwort in bezug auf
impfstoffproduktion auch in lizenz ob
sie die unternehmen hätten längst
verpflichten können diese ich weiß nicht
wie viele wie viele es menschen es gibt
die wissen wo in deutschland solche
dinge verfügbar gemacht werden können
wissen sie ist mittlerweile ist jetzt
eine woche her wheelock unternehmen ein
wir sind es ist es sind es sind ungefähr
zwei hände voll standorte die wirklich
hoch interessant sind in marburg ist
einer den haben wir in rekordzeit
genehmigt dass er nur ist das glas gibt
einige andere auch in den neuen ländern
und dann gibt es ganz viele die im
zulieferbereich aktiv sind und das ist
etwas wo ich den kollegen
jens spahn unterstütze weil
beispielsweise der impfstoff das eine
ist aber da müssen sie den verpacken in
sogenannte lipide und auf den lipide da
ist weltweit momentan eine knappheit und
alle kümmern sich darum
da sind wir da sind wir dabei und ich
bin überzeugt ich bin überzeugt dass wir
ab dem sommer auch sehr viel impfstoff
in deutschland haben sie das gemacht
hätten was sie jetzt machen wenn sie das
im vergangenen herbst gemacht hätten
dass sie sich umgeschaut hätten welches
unternehmen in deutschland könnte in
lizenz produzieren wenn der impfstoff
erfunden ist sozusagen dann könnten
diese unternehmen in lizenz produzieren
wenn sie das im herbst gemacht hätten
wenn wir dann war das nein das
hauptproblem war doch dass wir im herbst
und im sommer des letzten jahres
überhaupt gar nicht wussten welches
unternehmen einen impfstoff entwickeln
wird es gibt ganz viele unternehmen die
dabei waren zu entwickeln
und von denen gibt es nach hand
entwickelt schon bewusst endlich wieder
der erste ist der erfolg aber es gibt
zum beispiel unternehmen wie sanofi die
erklärt haben sie waren auf dem holzweg
und sie haben doch ganz lange keinen das
unternehmen cure weg ist erfolgreich die
werden hoffentlich sklaverei und die
waren auch genau so und dann haben wir
und dann haben wir in der tat das muss
man das muss man alles sich sehr genau
anschauen
wir haben ja ein system wo der
unternehmer zunächst einmal sagt ich
glaube meine entscheidung so dass alle
notwendigen dinge gemacht wenn wir zu
mir kommt und sagt kannst du mir helfen
ich brauche das oder das dann bin ich
als wirtschaftsminister dafür da zumal
wenn es um impfstoffe oder version geht
ja aber da es ja auch so sein kann sich
nicht hätten sein können dass sie
hingehen und sagen du machst das jetzt
darum darum geht es doch gar nicht die
freiwillige kooperation funktioniert die
frage ist nur warum sind denn einige
unternehmen nicht schon früher auf den
gedanken gekommen zusammenzuarbeiten
wir wissen noch nicht welches
unternehmen zu einem anderen passt diese
expertise hat keine bundesregierung und
kein minister sondern das müssen die
unternehmen selber machen und zwangs
lizenzen über die wir gesprochen haben
die sind dann notwendig wenn ein
unternehmen sich weigert
zu produzieren und impfstoff herstellen
zu lassen der hergestellt werden in der
situation sind wir aber derzeit nicht
weil im augenblick alles produziert wird
weil alles gebraucht wird letzte frage
haltmayer wald so lange dauert mit dem
impfen wird uns das späte spätere impfen
am ende den sommerurlaub kosten
zumindest sehr viel millionen deutschen
ich saß schon einmal bei ihnen und bin
gefragt worden nach dem sommerurlaub
damals bin ich gescholten worden weil
ich sagte ich kann es noch nicht
versprechen am ende konnten ganz viele
menschen in urlaub fahren und es war
doch noch ein bisschen sommerurlaub
übrig aber wir sind dann auch in eine
zweite welle hineingeschlittert und
deshalb wir fahren auf sicht und wir tun
alles damit die unternehmer wieder
arbeiten können aber nochmal die eine
relativ keine versprechen dagegen die
hand zu nehmen
gesagt ich hab den die politik so
verstanden der lok dann nur vier wochen
das haben wir natürlich nicht
vorhersagen was ihr dann nach wie vor
bei ist aber auch sagen wir jetzt
gehören wir können nichts versprechen
was man nicht hat aber das zielte gar
nicht auf dem versprechen sondern zielte
darauf dass es ja so lange dauert mit
dem impfen das heißt wenn wir eine
perspektive hätten dass familien im
mai/juni dass wir jetzt zu schaffen wenn
man so schnell geimpft hätte wie in
großbritannien oder den usa im mai juni
durch wäre dann könnte man jetzt planen
das ist normalerweise jetzt die zeit sie
sind dann tue ich das saftig
beteiligt mittlerweile haben also im
eigenen interesse in der der
reisebranche
das heißt ich kann demnächst bei ihnen
meine reise buchen weiß aber gar nicht
ob ich die reise überhaupt antreten aber
ich wenn weise ich bitte herzlich um
verständnis wir haben über die friseure
geredet ja und wie groß die not ist wir
haben über die gastronomie geredet wie
groß die not ist ich weiß was auch bei
den reisebüros die not groß ist dass die
menschen auch gerne verreisen aber ich
könnte es zum beispiel nicht
verantworten wenn ihr mal den hochrisiko
gebieten fährt
und wenn wir dann anschließend erleben
würden
das anstrengungen zunichte gemacht
werden die wir hier erfolgreich
durchgeführt haben
deshalb lassen sie uns darüber
nachdenken lassen sie uns das anschauen
und möglich machen was vertretbar ist
aber würden sie im moment sagen dann
buchen sie im moment nicht weil das das
ist keine ganz einfache praktische frage
im moment wenn man sie heute abend sieht
und man normalerweise ist das die
jahreszeit wo man das wenn man eine
familie hat heute bestätigt würde ich
würde jedem empfehlen
ich würde jedem empfehlen einige wochen
die situation zu beobachten um keine
entscheidungen zu treffen die man die
man nachher wieder revidieren muss aber
noch einmal dass es keine empfehlung des
wirtschaftsministers der gibt keine
empfehlungen an die menschen was sie tun
sie sollen sagen bitte sie haben den
reisekonzern ja ich weiß aber den
betreiben wir nicht als unternehmer
sondern ihm helfen wir zu überleben
damit auch in zukunft menschen verreisen
können in deutschland und im übrigen und
im übrigen tun wir alles damit klarheit
herrscht so bald wie möglich und kenne
die engländer die briten legen ihre
handtücher mallorca nämlich schon mal
hin die sind schon durch gekämpft aber
die haben die in großbritannien waren 11
prozent der menschen infiziert und die
zahl der toten ist wesentlich höher als
in deutschland beim impfen sind die
briten gut dass er kenne ich neidlos an
aber ich möchte trotzdem nicht tauschen
also sommerurlaub für die briten für die
deutschen eher noch nicht oder bzw mal
die situation wissen wir wissen wir
wissen ist nicht verstehe wissen es
nicht
danke herr altmaier für die
ja wie ich fand spannende runde für die
harte diskussion auch mit vielen von
denen die unternehmen locker und
wirklich existenziell im moment leiden
mit friseuren mit händlern mitwirken
danke für diese diskussion danke dass
sie sich gestellt haben der
wirtschaftsminister in ich danke allen
die zugeschaut haben und die selbst in
großer not sind weil sie unternehmen
haben die sie gerne vorgeben sind den
leuten eine perspektive diese woche dass
es glaube ich dass was millionen
deutsche erwarten danke für den besuch
bei bild und morgen geht es weiter mit
bild lifenews gleich am morgen mit einer
großen berichterstattung über den schnee
in deutschland bis dahin